just after days of accelerating violence
and new sign of escalation Israel said
it used a drone to strike a car carrying
Palestinian Fighters near the city of
Janine the result of a joint military
and intelligence operation it said the
man had earlier shot at a checkpoint and
were responsible for other recent
attacks it's the first acknowledged
targeted assassination by Israel in the
occupied West Bank in nearly 20 years
it had already been another violent day
Palestinians living in the village of
tomosiah described several groups of
armed settlers each group dozen strong
launching a coordinated attack deep into
the heart of their Community just before
one o'clock in the afternoon
do like this and
daytime Maman shalabi says 20 to 30
settlers attacked his house while 13
members of his family mine of them
children sheltered in a back room
they burned a car outside the gate and
then the two cars here then they threw
stones and shot live ammunition towards
the veranda and the windows we have
bullets inside the house
the village is just below the illegal
Israeli settlement of Shiloh where
minutes before the attack hundreds of
mourners had gathered for the funeral of
a 17 year old one of four people shot
dead in a Palestinian attack on a petrol
station on Tuesday it was on this road
in towards the Village from the
settlement Above the Law of the violence
took place first as villagers tried to
repel the settlers who were attacking
their homes and then there were
confrontations between Israeli forces
and the villagers as well people who
live here over the years have had to
grow used to repeated settler attacks
but they say they've never before seen
anything quite on this scale this was
the living room Bilal hajjaz's family
home is on the road one of the first the
attackers reached his mother and
eight-year-old son were inside Bilal was
on the other side of the group of
settlers I could see over 200.
in this street right here you know you
can look at it when I first walked you
know with my car I got real close to it
to them
they start throwing stones they even
shot on me I had to back up I did not
think about anything else but my mom and
my little boy they managed to shelter in
a store room bilalo was terrified of
finding their bodies in the main house
after they heard you know it was us not
them
um
they came out I mean when I saw them I
just fell on the floor and the violence
persisted into the night this was urif
home to the two Palestinian attackers
behind Tuesday's petrol station shooting
villagers there said they were attacked
by more than a hundred settlers Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera to a messiah in the
occupied West Bank